[Música]
la verdad ha sido una experiencia muy
linda hemos estado trabajando muy fuerte
en los últimos dos días pero tienen
en particular y artística muy buena todo
el mundo está escuchando y quieren
siempre sacar el mejor beneficio
artístico lo cual es para mí ese es una
maravilla como tener un manjar
fantástico para comer y deleitar los
todos yo vengo de venezuela ya tenemos
el sistema de esta creación maravillosa
del maestro josé antonio abreu
de no haber sido por su obra de haber
hecho el sistema tratar de a todas
partes yo vengo de una ciudad que no es
la capital yo vengo del puerto la cruz
en el este de la costa este de mi país y
de no haber sido por el sistema quizá
nunca hubiese descubierto la música
entonces mi país negro absolutamente
todo
beethoven justo con esta sinfonía él
cambió el rumbo de lo que iba a ser la
sinfonía y ya teníamos con hayden cómo
iba a ser la estructura de la sinfonía y
beethoven a partir de esta sinfonía
cambió todo y dejó muchos espacios para
luego se desarrollaran brahms brückner
madre todo lo que viene después para mí
es una grandísima inspiración y por
supuesto muchos andar cuando vas y se
toca mostrar con andrew tocando tan
fabuloso como está tocando es una
maravilla porque siempre tienes esa
frescura a pesar de que tiene unos
espacios que te llevan un poco de todos
sus conciertos este tiene unos cuantos
episodios que son bastante digamos
viendo un poco hacia el futuro que
estaba bastante avant garde para este
concierto y en ciertas partes de él pero
fue una maravilla porque podemos hacer
música y es como tener un poco de
champagne
frescura
a la cabeza
[Música]